to begin at the beginning no space no
time everything in the known universe
compressed into a dot smaller than an
atom
suddenly out of this the universe
expands stars and galaxies form creating
the cosmos we see today the story of our
universe starts with a big bang or does
it so the Big Bang is the observed truth
but there are details that haven't been
quite worked out
there are a lot of things that may have
happened it's just one explanation
science isn't about being right all the
time
it's about being wrong and we could
absolutely be wrong about a major
component in our understanding of the
universe we're putting one of Sciences
greatest stories to the test the Big
Bang sure sounds like an explosion but
was it
an explosion is a sudden release of
energy from one point usually generating
light heat pressure and a bank but did
the Big Bang even explode when you hear
the term bang you think of a noise but
you have to realize that its sound waves
propagating through air so after the Big
Bang there's no air there was no air
there's no way to hear anything so in
that sense it was silent
so the Big Bang didn't bang but to make
the universe it must have pushed out
stuff lots of stuff every explosion has
an ignition point what about the Big
Bang so if you were to only think of the
big bang as an explosion you would very
rightly ask well where's the center of
that explosion where is the center of
the universe there was no central point
there's nowhere in the sky you can point
and say that's where the Big Bang was
the Big Bang is everything the Big Bang
happened here where I'm sitting the Big
Bang happened on the other side of the
planet the Big Bang happened in the
Andromeda galaxy the Big Bang occurred
throughout the universe simultaneously
during an explosion debris fires out
from the center
this debris spreads out unevenly with
different sized pieces landing at
different distances from the blast
Center but did the Big Bang shoot
material out in this explosive manner
for clues we need to search the night
sky one of the things that's really very
striking about the universe when you
simply take a telescope and start
looking in different directions is that
it roughly speaking looks the same in
all directions
although the universe is peppered with
individual galaxies and galaxy clusters
the big picture is what astronomers call
homogenious when we say the universe is
homogeneous it means it's almost exactly
the same on very large scales with very
very little differences it's perfectly
smooth
if we believe the classic Big Bang story
the same amount of material was shot out
over the same distance in all directions
our smooth homogeneous universe doesn't
appear to be the result of what we know
as an explosion it wasn't big and it
wasn't a bang the Big Bang was not an
explosion like a grenade or a bomb or
dynamite where there is material rushing
out from a common center it's not like
there's a ring of galaxies that came out
from some explosion a firecracker
explosion is triggered by a fuse so what
set off the Big Bang what I would say is
there's no such thing as what triggered
to the Big Bang you know we tend to
think when something happens when
there's an effect there was a cause
right there was something that made it
happen but here we're talking about the
whole universe there's nothing outside
the universe to bring it into existence
the science is clear the universe did
not start with an explosion but if there
was no bang then how did everything
start so small and get so big the young
universe we do understand in the old
contemporary universe we also understand
we've stitched together this story where
we don't fully understand the first few
paragraphs of the story but we know the
rest of the book
how can we get to the bottom of the
BIGBANG story when we can't even read
the first page the book the only hope we
have is to search back in time line by
line one of the amazing things about
being a cosmologists is that telescopes
are time machines it takes a while for
light to get here so if we look farther
out into space we're really looking back
into the history of the universe and
that's amazing
the first clues to unraveling the Big
Bang mystery came with the introduction
of advanced telescopes in the 1920s
Edwin Hubble was studying the light
coming from distant galaxies and what he
realized was the more distant galaxy was
the more reddened the light was why
should that be well it turns out that
light retton's if a galaxy is moving
away from us it's called the redshift so
what he discovered was pretty much every
galaxy in the sky was moving directly
away from the Milky Way this was truly
one of Sciences landmark moments Hubble
had proved one of the basic principles
of the big bang story our universe is
continuously expanding there was only
one conclusion to draw if you
extrapolate that back in time it looks
like everything was coming from one
point at one time that's the Big Bang
Hubble's discovery grabbed the headlines
but the idea of an expanding universe
had been proposed two years earlier by a
Belgian priest and physicist
the real idea of the Big Bang comes from
George Lemaitre he realized that if you
ran time backwards back to the beginning
of time maybe everything coalesced into
a single atom the primeval atom
Lemaitre believed the infant universe
was extremely small and dense squeezed
into a single point the primeval atom
later
scientists would define this point as an
infinite entity called a singularity but
there's a problem the singularity and
the laws of physics don't mix it may be
one infinitely small point but it causes
some impossibly big problems
[Music]